[MUSIC]
If you look at Hollywood, there's these
companies that have been there for
a long time, Fox, Universal, Disney,
they've been making entertainment
product for a long time.
And now you have in Silicon Valley
companies that have been around for
a very short period of time,
the Facebooks, the Instagrams,
the Snapchats, and the question is, where
are we going to be in the decades to come?
Are those studios still going to be out
there making films the way they've been
doing for a long time?
And will these new companies be
continuing what they're going to do, or
are they going to morph
into something else?
[MUSIC]
The technology is amazing and
people love it and they love iMacs and
they love VR and they love all
the stuff that is coming along next.
However, people watch movies on their
iPhones, and if you're making a film and
you spend all this time working on it, and
someone's looking at in on an iPhone, you
feel like, well, jeez, I spent all this
time like worrying about the lighting and
the camera move and they're watching it
on an iPhone, but that's the reality of
the world that we're in, and that's
why I think story is still king here.
I watched this IMAX film
about climbing up Everest and
it was filmed spectacularly well,
and I thought it was pretty boring.
And then there's a scene there that's
amazingly powerful where somebody says
goodbye to their wife,
that they're dying on the mountain, and
it was filmed with this very cheap camera,
and that's what was moving,
that's what made the film memorable.
[MUSIC]
The thing to remember about Silicon Valley
is that technology is everywhere here.
The, sort of the joke is if you're
not paying for the product,
you are the product.
And so, there's an amazing amount of
data that's out there about what you do,
but there are places where data
can't really penetrate and
part of what makes films films is
you can't just look at the data.
If someone could have figured out
a formula for predicting movie success,
they would have done it a long time ago,
it would have been game over.
There still is something that comes
from the heart and the brain, and
that you try to come up with something
creative that engages an audience,
and wants them to hang in with your story,
and
wants them to forget about the sort
of the soccer game where they lost,
or the fact that their knee hurts, or
they gotta rush home to the babysitter,
that they get swept into
the part of the story, and
when you make a film, there's some
really rewarding parts of that.
I mean, there's moments when you're making
a film where you feel like the information
you're seeing is powerful and
it's touching, and
you hope that you have the skills,
and the technical abilities, and
the creative abilities to
bring that to an audience.
And if you're affected when you're doing
an interview in a documentary film, and
you look around and your entire crew is
crying, that they're moved by story, and
you're crying as well because someone's
telling such a powerful story,
you say to yourself, my God,
I hope that one day a movie theater full
of people will be just as affected, or
they'll watch it on TV and be affected.
And that is one-to-one, personal
storytelling, where the filmmaker's
trying to make a connection with
the audience, but then you hope it goes to
a wide audience and that people will
also have an emotional connection.
[MUSIC]
We are in a situation now where we had
a film at Sundance that came out this year
that was done all on the iPhone, the Oscar
winning documentary, Searching for
Sugarman, was shot partially on an iPhone,
I mean,
audiences have shown this kind of
willingness to embrace things shot
on cheap technology if
the story is compelling.
What does it make you start watching
at minute one and go to minute five and
stay all the way in there?
You need a compelling story
with people you care about.
It used to be in movies that you could
sort of trick people into going to see
a movie.
So you could spend lavishly
on newspaper and TV ads, and
by the time people realized
the film was terrible,
it was already a hit, well,
now it's hard to do that.
Now, people go into theaters, the movie
doesn't seem that good, on Friday night,
they're busy sending texts or going
out on Facebook, and I think it hurts
over publicized bad movies but
also helps under publicized good movies.
[MUSIC]
So if you look at Pixar,
that is a beautiful marriage because it's
technologically sophisticating, great,
and the storytelling is first rate, and
the way they work together is in
a highly collaborative way, and
that's everything working really well.
And so I think you're going to see more of
these examples coming forward as people
sort of admire the Pixar way.
And then so I think that, inevitably,
the two sides are going to become closer.
It's my stong belief that this is a
marriage of Silicon Valley and Hollywood,
sometimes they're
suspicious of each other,
sometimes they don't quite understand each
other, but we really need each other.
I mean, we're sitting right now
in the heart of Silicon Valley,
it's where products are designed,
it's where the cutting edge truly is.
On the other hand, when you're watching on
your iPhone, or your iPad, or your laptop,
or however you're watching,
there's gotta be content on that,
and there's not that much content that's
coming out of northern California,
the content is coming primarily
out of southern California, and
those are stories that
have to be well told.
And I think there's this idea that both
sides can learn from the other side,
and I think that with this marriage,
you're going to see increasingly better,
better shows, better delivered,
especially as an audience has come to
embrace this idea that audiences just
want good content and they don't really
care where it's coming from,
they will go to where the content is good.
[MUSIC]